succede che ci accorgiamo di qualcosa
non dalla sua presenza ma dalla sua
assenza come quando ci rendiamo conto di
un grande amore solo dalla sua mancanza
non dalla sua luce ma dalla sua ombra
buongiorno io oggi vi voglio parlare
della scoperta dei nuovi mondi
i nuovi mondi che noi scopriamo attorno
ad altre stelle non necessariamente
tramite la loro luce ma anche attraverso
la loro ombra oggi per nuovi mondi non
intendo quelli attorno al nostro sole e
quelli all'interno della stazione del
nostro sistema solare
questi sono per un certo verso
relativamente facile da esplorare
abbiamo mandato a macchine
sostanzialmente su ognuno di questi
recentemente anche attorno ad una cometa
mi riferisco a mondi che sono attorno a
stelle diverse dal nostro sole
questa storia inizia davvero una ventina
di anni fa quando eravamo in molti che
studiavamo come cercare di analizzare la
luce delle stelle intorno a noi per
cercare di estrarne la luce flebile dei
mondi che ruotano attorno a questi mondi
e come quando cerchiamo di aiutare un
amico che in difficoltà e che non
riusciamo a calarci nella sua realtà ma
cerchiamo di proiettare la nostra
esperienza ritenendola l'unica possibile
così allora in molti pensavano che i
mondi al di fuori del nostro sistema
solare potessero essere solamente come
il nostro ovvero sostanzialmente dei
piccoli pianeti rocciosi come la luna e
la nostra terra vicino alla stella è una
serie di pianeti giganti come giove e
saturno molto distanti e in effetti noi
pensiamo che così come su un picco
nevoso la neve rimane solo al di sopra
di una certa quota dove la temperatura
rimane al di sotto di una certa
grandezza analogamente a quello che noi
astronomi chiamiamo linea della neve non
si possono formare pianeti più vicini di
una certa distanza dalla stella
eppure vent'anni fa due astronomi
svizzeri con un telescopio sulle alpi
tutto sommato modesto non c'era big
science nel senso che oggi conosciamo ma
magari c'era big sinking nelle loro
menti e le loro fuori cercano quello che
la natura più fantasiosa di quello che
molti degli astronomi pensavano aveva
già messo in cielo in questo modo loro
scoprono il primo pianeta extrasolare a
il primo pianeta diverso da quelli che
sono all'interno del sistema solare
attorno a una stella simile alla nostra
che un pianeta molto più grande di giove
è molto più vicino dell'orbita di
mercurio questo pianeta un nome il nome
si chiama 51 peg b che è un nome diciamo
un po astruso che non rende giustizia
dell idea romantica di scoprire di
conquistare nuovi mondi
ebbene oggi sono passati 20 anni il
mondo è cambiato e voi potete scaricare
sul vostro cellulare una app che beep
beep beep dice ogni volta che un nuovo
pianeta viene scoperto 2000 pianeti sono
i più in poco meno di 2.000 sono i
pianeti che oggi si conoscono attorno ad
asti ad altre stelle sembra un grande
numero
ma in realtà io vi voglio convincere
questa sera che è un numero che si può
mettere contare con le dita di una mano
come si usa dire qui abbiamo la platea
giusta siete poco più di 600 700 persone
quindi se vi invito ad alzare le mani e
a mostrare tutte le dieci dita e in
questo momento se tutti li alziamo
grosso modo il numero di dita che stiamo
mostrando e circa 6mila come il numero
delle stelle visibili ad occhio non
ottenete tenente adesso un collega
armato passa a prendere monili e
preziosi per finanziare la ricerca
scientifica e ovviamente se voi andate
in una notte senza luna ne vedete
solamente la metà ne vedete 3000
contemporaneamente in altre tremila sono
nell'altro emisfero ora se fate 3 con la
mano tre così il numero di vita che
adesso ci sono qua in questa platea
corrisponde grosso modo al numero dei
pianeti che oggi sono conosciuti vorrei
farvi riflettere su questo 3 contro
un terzo 2000 pianeti contro 6 mila
stelle quattro secoli fa prima che
galileo galilei da questa città
puntassi col soprano chiara il cielo e
aprisse una nuova era astronomica si
conoscevano 6 mila stelle noi oggi
conosciamo 2000 pianeti meno di quei
pianeti che
siamo nell'epoca pre galileiana di
questa nuova scienza la maggior parte di
questi pianeti non è scoperta
analizzandone la luce ma è scoperta
analizzando nell'ombra questi pianeti
ruotano attorno alla stella e proiettano
un'ombra che si propaga a distanza di
dieci cento mille anni luce
e quando l'orbita della terra interseca
casualmente o perché l'astronoma è
sufficientemente paziente o da un
telescopio sufficientemente potente e
grande rivela questa flebile diminuzione
di luce e stabilisce del pianeta la
dimensione e l'orbita se noi vogliamo
scoprire molti più pianeti e vogliamo
poi analizzarne la composizione chimica
la temperatura capire se hanno un
atmosfera dobbiamo costruire via via
telescopi sempre più potenti
ovviamente c'è un limite al numero alla
dimensione di questi telescopi che
possiamo costruire sulla terra o che
possiamo andare nello spazio e a questo
scopo spesso si creano diciamo delle
ottiche cooperative per esempio in
questo caso abbiamo stiamo costruendo
qui a padova un satellite in cui 34
telescopi relativamente modesti circa di
potrete nello in braccio uno di questi
sono montati assieme in un unico
satellite per appunto scoprire nuovi
mondi oppure potremmo l'occhio
principale del telescopio la lente lo
specchio principale di questo telescopio
non costruirlo monoliticamente ma a
costruirlo mediante tasselli e come un
mosaico comporre lentamente tutta la
dimensione di un grande occhio di questo
telescopio questo che vedete è un
esempio
e un gioco fatto con i bambini in cui
abbiamo nel giardino dell'osservatorio
cittadino di questa città la specola
fatto portare dei bambini dei esagoni di
cartone di circa due metri di diametro
che vanno a comporre l'occhio principale
di un telescopio che stiamo costruendo
sulle ande cilene e questo è il lo
stesso esempio fatto sull'altopiano di
asiago vicino all'osservatorio
astrofisico adesso basta sostituire il
cartone con del vetro lavorato ticamente
risolvere un paio di problemi legali
legati allo sfruttamento del lavoro
minorile e il gioco sostanzialmente
fatto ma perché facciamo tutto questo
potrei raccontarvi che
cercando di costruire queste macchine
abbiamo inventato questa piccola
piramide di vetro che serve a sezionare
la luce delle stelle e che serve per
rivelare la luce del pianeta ma si è
rivelata utilissima noi non ce lo
immaginavamo neppure per studiare
l'occhio per esempio nel caso della
cataratta oppure che quest'altra
telescopio ad occhio di mosca l'abbiamo
chiamato per un evidente similitudine
che abbiamo inventato sempre qua padova
sta per iniziare a scandagliare il cielo
per cercare quello che si chiama la
spazzatura spaziale i detriti che sono
nell'orbita del nostro pianeta per
evitare che distruggono in modo
catastrofico irrimediabile satelliti per
telecomunicazioni e per
metereologia per per il gps ma in un
certo senso diciamo vi mentirei il vero
sogno ancestrale che ci sta dietro alla
fine è quello del viaggio noi vogliamo
cercare di guardare questi nuovi monti
cercare di scoprire questi nuovi mondi
perché un giorno vogliamo immaginare di
poterci andare e come tutti i viaggi che
si rispettano iniziano con una cartina e
per cui noi sostanzialmente stiamo
cercando di compilare una cartina il più
accurata possibile di quello che sono i
dintorni del nostro sistema solare per
un giorno riuscire ad arrivarci come
arrivarci per ora noi ci stiamo
occupando appunto di disegnare la
cartina di capire dove sono i mondi come
arrivarci oggi non lo sappiamo non
abbiamo la tecnologia per arrivare
tra le stelle più vicine ci sono molte
idee alcune buone alcune meno buone non
lo sappiamo
forse le idee migliori verranno devono
ancora essere essere scoperte
però possiamo provare a guardare
retrospettivamente dietro di noi e
capire cosa è successo nell'ultimo
secolo anzi negli ultimi 110 anni da
quando l'uomo vola con delle macchine
volanti allora sapete che la velocità
della luce pensiamo ancora sia
invalicabile quindi possiamo chiamare la
velocità di una macchina che costruiamo
come la velocità della luce è diviso per
esempio 10 diviso cento di riso mille e
contare il numero degli zeri che
mettiamo al denominatore
se facciamo così l'aereo dei fratelli
wright nel 1905 e ha una velocità pari
alla velocità della luce diviso 10
milioni che sono sette zeri in questa
scala è a sette zeri
gli aerei di linea che oramai a un
fenomeno di massa e prendiamo
probabilmente quasi tutti noi vanno una
velocità che è un milione più bassa di
quella dalle storia luce il numero degli
zeri e sei lì le astronavi che oggi
costruiamo e vanno nell'orbita attorno
alla terra come lo spezzato la soyuz
larian tutte più o meno vanno una
velocità superiore a quella della vista
della russia è diviso l'uno seguito da
cinque zeri le macchine più veloci che
l'uomo abbia costruito arrivano ad
essere leggermente più veloci della
verità della luce diviso un 1 seguito da
quattro zeri
ecco allora che in un secolo abbiamo
eroso tre zeri in questo denominatore e
se noi nel prossimo secolo riuscissimo a
mangiare altrettanti zeri a guadagnare
tre zeri nel 2 nominatore in questa
velocità potremmo pensare una missione
per mandare se non un equipaggio almeno
una macchina un robot
in una delle stelle più vicine in 10 20
30 anni
questo è un sogno ovviamente ma il sogno
non è solamente legittimo io credo che
il sogno sia un imperativo io credo che
noi dobbiamo continuare nel nostro
lavoro di cercare di scoprire questi
nuovi pianeti di catalogarle di fare
macchine che riescono a fare cose via
via più incredibili di mettere nel
nostro lavoro quella aliquota di follia
per evitare di rifare le stesse strade
percorse da altri per cercare di
costruire macchine che fra una roba e
fantastiche che noi oggi neanche ci
immaginiamo le cose facili non ci
interessano e vogliamo conquistare nuovi
mondi grazie